[Music]
when you were watching last night on
that big screen was there a moment that
gave you chills or kind of made you feel
like I mean I I think any time the
audience reacted cuz I was what was new
you know for us cuz I've been sitting
with my editors you know Michael Shaw
birthday Lieberman sitting in the
impulse with them for for a long time
you know it's been a better part of a
year and we would do you know very small
screenings but you know as far as like
seeing in a long full of people I almost
forgot what that felt like
you know cuz I hadn't done it since it's
just my last film you know and they've
been you know a couple couple years have
changed you know so so that was the that
was the part that I was react us I okay
so so they you know so they got that
thing and but I reacted to this to this
to this bit here into that what I
talking to the screen cuz you know my
family I had a bunch of my family come
down from the bay and they were like it
was acting like that was in like AMC or
some you know it was there was you know
Oakley was gonna stand upright news
people standing up well I didn't bring
on my way there that part of it was like
okay you know you feel something there
but as far as the movie you know we saw
had too many involved with it that I
mean you feel close to all of it you
know I mean but but uh as far as parts
to hear me chills or like know that's
tough you know the waterfall scene did
that for me
really it it was one of the most
beautifully shot scenes oh it it was
really magical it really was I mean I
felt myself because I love movies too
but I just felt myself going from the
bottom to the top of the screen like
literally with my head like this like
mmm steena 3d oh why is it coming out oh
yeah yeah yeah okay was there ever a
point in this process that you doubted
yourself or you
every day yeah yeah Donna myself this
morning no yeah I mean I struggle with I
struggle with self-doubt and I you know
I you know you know I'm a mom my life is
limited to my own perspective but I
struggle with self-doubt all the time
you know obviously I feel very at home
making movies every day you get that
voice it's like man you know you can't
really do this you know you're a fraud
you know it's never it's never work you
know you get that we get that voice in
it and it's normal I mean I think I
white
yeah I imagine a white girl sure like
before you before you got to go to the
ER thing you get you got that you hear
that voice it was like I mean I already
finish it this morning I'm like I hope
they don't think I'm an idiot
you never she's loud man come on I had
to learn you know from plants were
sideways was you know boys would tear
I'd you know in I had to learn how to
tell it to shut up you know saying what
are you doing a good job keep making
these 200 million dollar budget movies
keep making these that's what that voice
is good
you know Marvel has been criticized some
times in the past for their villains and
and maybe not fully realizing or maybe
not getting them quite right but kill
monger is right
oh yes yes why do you think he works so
well as a villain we blessed I have you
know very talented actor in our role
Michael B Jordan was very charismatic
and I think that um Mike has a way of
making scenes and situations feel real
and and he has something about him that
triggers an empathy you know I think um
with with people no matter what he's
doing no matter you know I you know so I
think that that's in a way it's kind of
a secret weapon you know he's somebody
who you care about almost as soon as you
see him you know I saw it was
interesting like an awful for me knowing
him and when he's never done it's never
played a bad guy and you know come on
it's pretty bad you know I mean if you
really think about like what he does in
the film
and so I was a challenging thing you
know we wanted to have a villain that
was complicated and we wanted to have a
villain that could challenge to
childhood and it kind of hit him where
it where he's most vulnerable you know
if it just I was not a vulnerable person
like you know in the comic books on this
not in this film he's incredibly
powerful and strong and smart and hard
to get to you know you know as a you
know as a sovereign leader of a nation
should be you know so you know I think
that they into childhood being such a
such a uniquely gifted hero you know we
needed a uniquely gifted villain to
challenge did you ever play around with
having anyone else from the Marvel
Universe in the movie know why I was in
other movies but other people didn't
know in the comic books yes there was
something that we that we that we
definitely play around with trash you
know like an early drafts like I was
looking at you know you look at you look
at everybody look at the horrors gallery
and you want to try a representation um
I'm in there some of them I can't really
talk about specifically but you've never
thought about Iron Man or Captain
America or any of those guys maybe
bringing them in no no no when you
started thinking about the sequel you
heard me when I said win right you know
fans want x-men to come back maybe can
do you think maybe you can fit storm or
somebody like that I know I'm sure talk
about black pants guys all I could talk
about you know that's like I think about
at home you say you're not even thinking
about making a sequel yet no I'm
thinking about um give a responsible and
insightful answers to people says just
so yeah you got it we got it we got a
home you know sell the movie you get it
out there you know that's my sauce for
my haze I'm still I'm at the last stage
of make of
delivering the baby okay well last
question then because people are critics
are already calling this Marvel's most
political film to date and most
important in terms of content there were
a couple things that really like stood
out that last monologue by des Chawla
bye-bye
Black Panther felt like you might wrote
that last week how we did we wrote the
script you know Joe and I wrote this
script man were you speaking pointedly
two years ago were you speaking to the
president well like maybe not if you
wrote it two years ago we talked about
building bridges not building you know
like it felt like you were speaking but
I think that's an African proverb yeah a
South African proverb don't want that my
wife found um you know while we were
working on it but but not we wrote that
we wrote that stuff Obama was president
you know we try to pour from obviously
current climate you know what we're
really looking at was was uh really just
making like knowing to chocolate as a
character and normally would he goes
through in the film you know I find
myself looking up to the to the to that
character you know I mean like an
aspiring aspiring uh today that sound
mal cool would it be if if this person
was you know was it was was really in it
and it's not different from what I think
father out there so well with Iron Man
Iron Man one and it turns I'm making a
character that is just I wished I do it
was really around the world looks like
they're the real place I was aware of
the iron man who could jump in a suit
and go and you know it's a cool stuff
and press conferences and running you
know so so so for us you know when
people say you know this film is a
political movie I mean black pad as a
politician you know it's the first MCU
movie about a politician you know so I
should you know I should be the most
political and and and it's the thing
where you know if this character has to
make a governmental address like what
kind of stuff will he say so I was hot
come on he asked ourselves that stuff we
looked for African proverbs you know it
was like you know about embracing the
world and because you know in and I that
was kind of how we how we found some of
that stuff you know
um sort of saw that nicely truth day
[Music]